your character
it feels like it's such a great ensemble
cast your character is constantly being
humiliated in different ways he is which
is and you play it so well it's so
enjoyable to watch last season your
character
jonah uh he converted to judaism he does
and then he decides he wants to get
circumcised as an adult
yeah to make his his fiancee who treats
him terribly by the way uh
he decides to get uh adults circumcised
for her and of course she immediately
unceremoniously dumps him after he does
it
moments after he has woken up from
from the ash from the anesthesia and
within five minutes she's dumped him
but
when i heard that this was gonna happen
being a responsible a responsible actor
i wanted to do research and not on
judaism because i thought it would be
really funny if he knew nothing about
judaism but knew a lot about adult
circumcision
and
uh so as a responsible actor i went i
remembered that i have a really good
friend from college who was adult
circumcised he got certain what's what
age was he circumcised 16 17. oh like
the worst time for that to happen yeah
and uh i i'm just i'm imagining that is
incredibly painful from everything from
every story he told about and he was as
you would imagine pretty reserved about
his stories that he shared with us but
he it was apparently i'm amazed you knew
in the first place yeah who goes around
telling people oh yeah by the way they
sent me when i was 16. yeah and i it was
for no religious reason i honestly have
no idea outside of maybe just aesthetics
yeah
so i i call them up there's a really
good friend of mine from college i
called him up and i was like hey man
you're not gonna believe this i know
that it's been 18 years
i have a couple questions for you about
adult circumcision
and it's timely so if you could just hit
me back let me know just please like hit
me back i want to know um i still have
not received a phone call back right
i don't know why he wouldn't want to
delve back
why does he want to go back into the
most painful experience of his life